erreichen wie auch den
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck vorgeladen
vor den Wirtschafts- und
energieausschuss der wurde
zusammengelegt auf Wunsch der Grünen da
hat man dann gemeinsam die Fragen
beantwortet und die Opposition hat
gesagt das reicht uns nicht wir wollen
in der vergangenen Woche die beiden
Herren erneut hören diesmal in
öffentlicher Anhörung aber das alles ist
nicht ausschlaggebende Grund so wie der
Spiegel ist meldet muss es wohl weitere
Ungereimtheiten geben bei der Vergabe
von Gutachten es gab nämlich eine
hausinterne Prüfung aller Vorgänge und
offensichtlich ist dort erneut etwas
vorgefallen Patrick reichen jedenfalls
wird jetzt in den einstweiligen
Ruhestand versetzt und wir warten auf
eine Pressekonferenz mit Robert Habeck
der sich dazu gleich erklären dürfte
genau da schalten wir gleich hin wie
sehr stand denn Robert habe jetzt in der
Zwischenzeit unter Druck
ja das hat man ja mitgekriegt wenn man
die Zeitung aufschlug allen halben der
Absturz seiner persönlichen
Beliebtheitswerte der Absturz der Grünen
in Bremen der Druck auf die Grünen und
auf den Wirtschaftsminister war enorm
stark aber dennoch hat Robert Habeck an
seinem wichtigsten Mann in der
vergangenen Woche noch festgehalten er
hat ja auch fast trotzig gesagt also
ohne den Herrn reichen hätten wir den
Winter überhaupt nicht überstanden das
sind natürlich kindische Argumentationen
das muss auch der Wirtschaftsminister
wissen es muss nach Recht und Gesetz zu
gehen man kann nicht Trauzeugen einen
Spitzenjob zuschanzen man kann
offensichtlich Gutachten auch nicht
einfach nach gut düngen vergeben also da
ist eine Vetternwirtschaft im Gange
gewesen die dringend unterbunden gehört
und ein Staatssekretär hätte schon bei
dieser Trauzeugen Geschichte merken
müssen das ist ein Auswahlprozess der
über mehrere Wochen geht dass das so
nicht gehen kann er hat sich erst nach
der Auswahl seines trauzeugens bei dem
Wirtschaftsminister gemeldet hat gesagt
und ich habe da glaube ich einen Fehler
gemacht aber all dieses
wie gesagt scheint jetzt mit neuen
Vorwürfen bei der Gutachten Vergabe
aufgefranzt zu werden und deswegen ist
dieser Mann offensichtlich nicht mehr zu
halten obwohl ja die fachliche Eignung
von Patrick reichen niemand in Frage
stellt und auch nicht von Michael
Schäfer das ist ein Trauzeuge der
zunächst diesen Job bekommen hatte
das ist es und viele gerade auch aus der
Opposition sagen das ist der Agora
Energiewende da kommen die alle her das
ist ein Think Tank mit wenigen Leuten
die plötzlich die Energiepolitik von
Deutschland komplett auf den Kopf
gestellt haben Robert Habeck hat ihn
blind vertraut hat diese Freundeskreise
machen lassen das sagt zumindest die
Opposition und es dürfte spannend sein
wer der Nachfolger wird von Patrick
reichen denn für Robert Habeck entsteht
mit dem Weggang seines Spitzenbeamten
ein großes Loch und ähm da muss er jetzt
erstmal sehen dass er den richtigen
Nachfolger dann auch findet die Grünen
hatten ja schon im Vorfeld eigentlich
versucht auch diese sehr diversen
Verpflichtungen im
Wirtschaftsministerium offen zu legen
aber vieles auch schon im Vorfeld
bekannt wie kann es sein wenn man da
doch eigentlich die Sensibilität hatte
dass dann aber so etwas das ist mein
Trauzeuge nicht rechtzeitig offengelegt
wird wie kann sowas passieren
ja das ist Versagen eines Spitzenbeamten
in dem Fall völlig unabhängig mit wem
ergreifend ist hätte er als
Staatssekretär bei der Ausschreibung des
dna-jobs wissen müssen einer von den ich
glaube 9 Kandidaten ist mein Trauzeuge
ein ganz enger Freund von ihm Michael
Schäfer und ja er hätte einfach damals
schon sagen müssen also ich kann in
dieser Berufungskommission das waren nur
drei Personen nicht mitmachen er hat
dann hinter sich gerechtfertigt er habe
viele von den Kandidaten geduzt auch das
zeigt noch mal die innere Verpflichtung
und das eben diese Energiewende die
Robert habe ich eingeleitet hat vor
allen Dingen von der Agora Energiewende
Personalien mitbestimmt worden ist das
ist ein großer Freundeskreis viele davon
sind im Ministerium gelandet Michael
Schäfer wie gesagt hat diesen
hochdotierten Job bekommen ihn dann aber
nicht angetreten und offensichtlich mit
dem heutigen Tag ist Patrick reichen
auch nicht mehr dabei ist das denn nur
bei den Grünen so und beim Thema
Energiewende das ist diese Verflechtung
und Bekanntschaften gibt oder gibt's das
auch in anderen Ministerien
also das so viele
Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse vorliegen ja
beide Staatssekretäre sind Schwäger dann
hat man eben eine Schwester von einem
gleichen einen Bruder bei dem
Ökoinstitut arbeiten dort hatte schon
Herr Altmaier der Vorgänger von Herrn
Harbeck viele Gutachten etc Auftrag
gegeben das hat jetzt habe ich auch
gemacht aber das hat alles natürlich so
ein bisschen geschmeckle es ist deshalb
vor allen Dingen für die Grünen und
Herren havix ein bisschen tragisch wenn
man z.B weil die Bücher von Robert habe
liest und die Worte man will eine andere
Politik machen dann sieht man das hat
nicht geklappt und jetzt sie sehen es
geht los genau
ja schönen guten Tag herzlich willkommen
zu einem Präsident mit Bundesminister
Robert Habeck der Bundesminister hat das
Wort
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die
letzten Wochen wurden von der Debatte
über die neue Besetzung der DNA sehr
stark überschattet es ist ohne Frage ein
Fehler passiert und wir haben über
diesen Transparenz hergestellt wir haben
die Hebel in Bewegung gesetzt damit die
Geschäftsführung der Diener neu
ausgeschrieben wird und die gehen ja
dann befreit von Verdacht von
Interessenkonflikten arbeiten kann
wir haben außerdem die Berichterstattung
rund um die Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse
von Patrick reichen zum Anlass genommen
um die compliance-verfahren die auf
diesen Gründen etabliert wurden zu
überprüfen und Transparenz bei Vergaben
und Zuwendungen herzustellen diese
Prüfung wurden am 23 April beauftragt
wir haben zwischenzeitlich die Listen
der Anträge und Zuwendungen
veröffentlicht
daraus können Sie entnehmen dass die
Aufträge und Zuwendung an das
Ökoinstitut nicht gestiegen sind sie
bewegen sich in dem Bereich der in den
Vorjahren unter einer anderen
politischen Leitung üblich war das
gleiche gilt für die Zuwendung an den
buen die
das bmwk hat auch die Vorgänge die zu
Aufträgen und die Zuwendungen geführt
haben auf Herz und Nieren geprüft es
wurde von unserem zentralen
rechtsreferat festgestellt dass seit
Beginn der Legislaturperiode wie von den
compliance-verfahren vorgesehen keine
Entscheidung über Aufträge oder
Zuwendungen an das Ökoinstitut oder
Zuwendung an den Bund eV und der
Beteiligung von staatssekretärreichen
getroffen wurden das gilt auch für die
Zuwendung anderen
wir haben auch die Verfahren kritisch
geprüft und bewusst sehr kritische und
kleinteilige nachfragen und auch
Nachfragen gestellt im Zuge dieser
Prüfung ist nun ein Sachverhalt
aufgetaucht zudem mir seit gestern Abend
ein Prüfergebnis vorliegt
dieses Prüfergebnis ist der Grund für
die heutige Pressekonferenz
es ist ein Sachverhalt der bisher
öffentlich nicht diskutiert wurde und
über den ich nun Transparenz herstelle
dieser Sachverhalt hat mich im Rahmen
der internen Prüfung erstmal am Dienstag
letzter Woche erreicht die erste
kosorische Einschätzung war aber
entlassend es stellten sich aber eine
Reihe von Fragen und um weitere
Erklärung und mündliche Prüfung habe ich
daraufhin gebeten
bei diesen Sachverhalt handelt es sich
um einen Vorgang im Rahmen der
Nationalen Klimaschutzinitiative
es ist eine sogenannte Aufforderung zur
Antragstellung also eine Vorstufe für
eine konkrete förderantragstellung
entsprechend der Vorlage hat am 30.11 22
Patrick reichen eine Liste mit drei
Projektskizzen gebilligt eines dieser
Projekte stammt vom Bund Landesverband
Berlin mit einer Fördersumme von knapp
600.000 Euro
es ist noch kein Geld geflossen aber das
Projekt wurde mit der Abzeichnung als
förderwürdig eingestuft die finale
Förderentscheidung war damit im Prinzip
nur noch eine reine Formsache
es ist der Landesverband nicht der
Bundesverband allerdings ist im
Landesverband Berlin die Schwester von
Patrick reichen Vorstandsmitglied sie
hat zwar keine formale
Vertretungsbefugnis war aber laut
Vereinsregister bis Mai 22
Landesvorsitzende
insofern ist es wie die tiefere Prüfung
zeigt als Compliance Verstoß zu bewerten
diese Vorlage hätte Patrick reichen laut
Compliance Regel wieder vorgelegt werden
dürfen noch hätte er sie abzeichnen
dürfen es muss schon allein der Anschein
der Parteilichkeit vermieden werden und
das ist hier nicht eingehalten worden
außerdem gibt es einen zweiten Vorgang
der in einem Graubereich liegt und den
wir deshalb im Zuge der Prüfung noch
einmal ausgeleuchtet haben
es ist die Besetzung der
Expertenkommission zur Energiewende
Monitoring bei der unter anderem Felix
mattes als Experte beauftragt wurde
der Vorgang liegt schon länger zurück
auch hier kommt nun die vertiefte
Prüfung die mir seit gestern vorliegt zu
dem Schluss dass der Anschein der
Parteilichkeit besser hätte vermieden
werden sollen
um es festzuhalten auch hier hat sich
die Einschätzung geändert von erst
entlastend nun zu belastend
die Fehler sind unterschiedlich
gravierend und stünde jeder dieser
Fehler für sich allein würde er eine
solch dramatische Konsequenz wie wir sie
heute ziehen nicht nötig machen
aber die Fehler stehen eben nicht für
sich allein sondern sind in der
Gesamtschau zu sehen
ich habe mich in den letzten Wochen
trotz des schweren Fehlers bei der
Diener Neubesetzung vor Patrick reichen
gestellt menschen machen Fehler jeder
und jede von uns
aber um den einen schweren Fehler zu
verteidigen bzw damit umgehen zu können
muss ich sicher sein dass die Compliance
Brandmauer die wegen der
Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse gezogen
wurde keine Risse hat
diese Risse hat sie nun
in der Gesamtschau hat sich Patrick
reichen damit zu angreifbar gemacht um
sein Amt noch wirkungsvoll ausüben zu
können
vor diesem Hintergrund sind Patrick
reichen und ich gestern Abend in einem
persönlichen Gespräch darin
übereingekommen dass wir die gemeinsame
Arbeit nicht fortsetzen ich beabsichtige
daher den Bundespräsidenten zu bitten
Patrick reichen in den einstweiligen
Ruhestand zu versetzen
ich möchte hier ausdrücklich sagen das
Patrick reichen in den letzten Wochen
über das berechtigte Maß an Kritik und
Aufklärung zu angefeindet wurde von
mitunter rechtsextrem Accounts Lügen
über die Familie verbreitet und von
puristischen Accounts weiter gepusht
worden ist unerträglich was macht mir
große Sorgen
ich weiß es ist nicht das erste und es
wird sicherlich nicht das letzte Mal
sein aber so können und so dürfen
politische Debatten nicht ausatmen
Patrick reichen hat große Leistung für
dieses Land erbracht er hat durch sein
überaus großen Einsatz Deutschland vor
einer gasmangelage bewahrt und
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen eine
Wirtschaftskrise abzuwenden er hat die
Energiewende wieder flott gemacht und
Klimaschutz zum Regierungshandeln
dafür danke ich Ihnen ausdrücklich
die Abzeichnung der bund-vorlage fällt
in die Hochphase der Krise
es war eine Phase extremer Arbeitslast
aber das ändert nichts an der
Gesamtschau es ist der eine Fehler zu
viel
deshalb habe ich heute diese
Entscheidung getroffen es ist eine
weitreichende
schwere Entscheidung weitreichend für
mein Haus schwer für mich und sehr hart
für Patrick reichen
es geht aber darum das Vertrauen in die
Arbeit dieses Hauses als Institution zu
schützen es geht darum die politische
Handlungsfähigkeit zu wahren ich werde
nun zügig eine Nachfolge bestellen
ich möchte abschließend noch einmal
deutlich machen
ich möchte mich explizit gegen die
pauschalen Anwürfe gegenüber meinem Haus
und dem Leitungsbereich verwahren
was zurecht in den Blick gerückt ist ist
die Frage von Compliance sie ist wichtig
weil es um das Vertrauen in die
Unabhängigkeit von politischen
Entscheidungen und Gesetzgebungen geht
wir haben in der Bundesverwaltung ein
gutes Regelwerk und dem bmwk haben wir
dementsprechend die Verfahren der
Vorgängerregierung übernommen diese
setzen stark auf Eigenverantwortung
entlang dann dem Regelwerk aber die
Debatte zeigt auch dass es sinnvoll ist
die compliance-verfahren noch einmal zu
überprüfen und zu schauen wie wir
Kohärenz Stringenz und Transparenz
stärken und verbessern können das tun
wir bereits für das bmwk und werden das
sicherlich auch innerhalb der
Bundesregierung besprechen damit die
Bundesverwaltung möglichst einheitlich
auf den selben Maßstäben arbeitet vielen
Dank
vielen Dank an Bundesminister Robert
Habeck wir haben Zeit für drei
Nachfragen georg ist man macht den
Anfang
können Sie noch mal etwas genauer sagen
worum es ging bei dieser Vorlage die
dort oder vorgeschlagen wurde eben als
förderungswürdig und in welchem Zeitraum
gedenken Sie eine Nachfolge
vorzuschlagen weil wir jetzt ja auch
mitten in dem parlamentarischen
Beratungen sind zum Beispiel zum
heizungsgesetz
so schnell wie es geht nun war das
gestern ein intensiver und
ja auch fordernder Abend also verzeihen
Sie mir dass ich heute nicht gleich in
der Nachfolge präsentieren kann ich
würde dann hier nach der Pressekonferenz
anfangen dafür zu arbeiten aber
natürlich so schnell wie es geht die
Hoffnung ist das noch vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause so dass
also auch noch die Beratung fürs gegi
dann mitgeführt werden können
hinzubekommen und der Vorgang selbst
setzt sich so zusammen es gibt im Rahmen
der nationalen Klimaschutz Initiative
verschiedene
Projektfenster dafür gibt es dann
Anträge von Vereinen oder von Verbänden
in diesem konkreten Fall waren es 29
Anträge aus diesen 29 Anträgen hat eine
ein unabhängiger
Dienstleister drei ausgewählt diese drei
vorgeschlagen diese drei sind
mitgezeichnet worden durch das Haus die
Hierarchie hoch und landeten dann auf
dem Schreibtisch von Patrick reichen und
wurden dann wie gesagt am 30.11
gebilligt
dann bitte Hinterleitner
das bedeutet diese Rücktritt ihr Haus da
jetzt
nicht gut da steht für die wärmewende
wird da der Architekt dieser werbewände
wird jetzt fehlen und die Opposition
sicherlich alles was an Schwäche hier im
Haus verspürt wird zu nutzen versuchen
sehen sie da so wie es geplant haben
gefährdet im Parlament
nun
die wärmewende damit ist der
wahrscheinlich gemeint das Gebäude
Energiegesetz es ist jetzt ja bekannt
dass es mehrfach beschlossen wurde in
koalitionsausschüssen letztmalig bei dem
sagenumwobenen 30 Stunden
Koalitionsausschuss
da wurde auch beschlossen ist vor den
Sommerferien zu verabschieden
das Kabinett hat dann zeitnah eine
Einigung erzielt diese Einigung muss ich
als
Grundlage der weiteren Beratungen werden
denn alle haben die mir zugestimmt ein
kabinett entscheidet immer einstimmig
und damit haben sozusagen Partei und
Fraktionsführung auch innerhalb der
verschiedenen Regierungspartner gesagt
so wollen wir es jetzt machen das
Gesetze im parlamentarischen Verfahren
immer verändert werden besser werden
hoffentlich was ist natürlich
selbstredend noch einmal mir ist wichtig
dass wir den Einstieg in die erneuerbare
Wärme jetzt hinbekommen das Gesetz wie
im Kabinett beschlossen sieht aus meiner
Sicht jede Form von Pragmatismus jetzt
schon vor
technologieoffenheit Übergangsfristen
härtefallregeln Ausnahmen und so weiter
und so fort diese verschiedenen Regeln
kann man sich sicherlich genau noch mal
anschauen und noch mal genau justieren
und schauen ob man das noch klüger und
besser machen kann es ist ja immer gut
wenn Sachen klüger und besser gemacht
werden
aber es sollte nicht damit verwechselt
werden und auch kein Rückfall gegenüber
den kollisionsausschuss hergestellt
werden der sagt wir trauen ist da doch
nicht dran das wäre dann sozusagen nicht
mehr entlang der Vereinbarung
dann bitte Frau Matus mit der letzten
Frage wir müssen danach zum Schluss
kommt Frau Martus bitte
Frau Matus außen genau da
habe wie wollen Sie denn bei dem
ausfallprozess für den Nachfolger
sicherstellen dass es einerseits jemand
ist der die Expertise für das Amt hat
und gleichzeitig nicht ähnlich wie
Patrick reichen wieder so viele
Verbindungen die hier den anscheinend
von Voreingenommenheit bringen könnten
wir haben bei dem Auswahl Prozess des
dem zweiten Auswahl Prozess der Diener
eine Regel vorgesehen wo die Leute aktiv
gefragt werden also nicht wie es die
Compliance Regeln sind achtet darauf
dass ihr keine verbindung habt und
vermeidet den anscheinend von
Parteilichkeit sondern aktiv gefragt
gibt es Verbindung zu einem der
Kandidaten und ich glaube dieser dieses
aktive Abfragen ist der Eintritt den wir
insgesamt einführen sollten und
ansonsten sind natürlich auch alle
gewarnt durch die aktuelle Debatte sich
auf Herz und Nieren zu überprüfen also
das denke ich wird auch automatisch
passieren dass wir
also ich würde ihn nicht mehr in
Trauzeugen jetzt als Staatssekretär
Berufen
vielen Dank danke dass Sie so
kurzfristig erschienen sind ich wünsche
Ihnen einen schönen Tag und alles Gute
vielen Dank
ja soweit Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
Patrick reichen der Staatssekretär muss
gehen und wir sprechen darüber noch mal
mit Gerd Joachim von verlor was war ihr
Eindruck von dieser Pressekonferenz
ja es war ein typischer Robert Habeck er
wirkte zerknirscht er hat auf die Frage
Nachfolge wie gesagt also ich musste
erstmal gestern mit dem gleichen dieses
schwierige ist es völlig klar dass
natürlich seit gestern auch die
Nachfolgesuche schon läuft so ist das im
politischen Berlin ähm Herr Kreisen ist
nicht der erste Staatssekretär der gehen
muss aber vielleicht einer der
wichtigsten in der jetzigen Frage das
heizungsgesetz wurde er angesprochen er
ist so ein bisschen das Brain hinter der
gesamten Energiepolitik dieser Regierung
vor allen Dingen dieses
Wirtschaftsministers und wenn er jetzt
gehen muss dann darf man wirklich
gespannt sein wer sein Nachfolger wird
es reißt jedenfalls eine große Lücke
Robert habe in dieser Pressekonferenz so
getan als wenn es dann Verfehlungen
waren die dann am Schluss vielleicht
dann doch nicht mehr ist möglich machten
den Mann zu halten in Wirklichkeit hätte
er sich von seinem Staatssekretär schon
in der vergangene Woche spätestens
trennen müssen da sind sich alle im
politischen Berlin einig die Folge
Schäden für ihn und aber auch für vor
allen Dingen die grüne Parteien Bremen
hat man es gesehen sehen aber insgesamt
für die Ampel die sind ja durchaus zu
sehen und insofern hat er hier
vielleicht auch als falsch verstandener
Freundschaft vielleicht auch weil er ihn
dringend gebraucht hat den Patrick
reichen viel zu lange an diesem Mann
festgehalten dass ein Staatssekretär
wegen interner Compliance Regelung gehen
muss ist nicht der die Regel aber ist
auch schon mal vorgekommen und in diesem
Fall besonders spektakulär ihre
Einschätzung nach wie sehr hat die Wahl
in Bremen dazu jetzt beigetragen zu
diesem Sinneswandel
naja wir haben es gehört das war eher
die hausinterne Prüfung von Vorgängen
und der Vorwurf der Opposition des Films
ist der war ja so ein bisschen in der
vergangenen Woche wie ich will nicht
sagen abgeräumt aber nachdem Robert habe
gesagt hat er steht hinter seinem
Staatssekretär der Trauzeuge das war ein
Fehler den zu berufen der hat jetzt den
Job gar nicht angetreten hatte man so
das Gefühl zumindest scheinbar aus Sicht
von Robert habe der dickste Brocken sei
abgeräumt aber dass diese Verfügung eben
diese Geschichte die im Vorfeld auch als
relativ harmlos diskutiert wurde wer
alles mit wem verwandt ist dass diese
Geschichte letzten Endes zum Rücktritt
führt ist dann doch interessant sie
haben mich ja vorhin auch gefragt also
wenn ein Staatssekretär mit den
handelnden Akteuren in seinem Bereich
der Art verwandtschaftliche Beziehung
hat wie z.B seine Schwester die bei mir
und du die sitzt und letzten Endes dann
abgezeichnet ein Fördervertrag von 600
000 € von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
von Wirtschaftsministerium bekommt dann
geht es eben nicht so dumm ist für
Verwandtschaft kann man nichts aber die
Ver Leistungen in diesem Bereich
Verpflichtungen Paarungen in diesem
Bereich die waren einfach so groß dass
im Grunde genommen dort ein
Staatssekretär saß der sich am besten in
keine Entscheidung eingemischt hätte um
den Compliance Regeln zu genügen aber
das ging natürlich nicht er war der
Zentrale Akteur und er hat dann eben
gewirkt und wir sehen er hat bei der ein
oder anderen Stelle übers Ziel ist er
hinausgeschossen man er hätte als
tatsächlicher genauer hingucken müssen
was er wann wo abzeichnet aber das ist
in dem Posten glaube ich sehr sehr
schwer wenn hinter jeder Ecke dann eine
persönliche Verquickung zu vermuten ist
also das wäre ein gefundenes Fressen
gewesen für die Opposition die ja auch
gesagt hat wir werden einen ähm
Untersuchungsausschuss anstreben wenn
das nicht aufgeklärt wird in den
Ausschüssen also da ist jetzt noch mal
die letzte Notbremse gezogen worden aber
wie ich finde eigentlich zu spät und
jetzt hat Minister habe gesagt auf die
Frage hin wie wollen Sie das in Zukunft
verhindern naja wir wollen noch mal
stärker hingucken beim Thema Compliance
und die Leute aktiv vorher fragen gibt
es Verbindung kennen Sie einen der
Kandidaten was ist denn wenn die Antwort
immer ja lautet was das soll man machen
ja das ist auch eine interessante Frage
natürlich gerade in solchen Bereichen
wie dem Wirtschaftsministerium das gilt
zum Beispiel auch für
Verkehrsministerium da sind ja die mit
denen man zu tun hat in der Tat eine
Gruppe die gar nicht so riesengroß ist
und natürlich kennt man sich
untereinander aber sich untereinander zu
kennen und dann am Schluss von einem
Auswahlverfahren von neun Personen
seinen eigenen Trauzeugen auf den
Spitzenposten zu berufen das ist schon
mal ein großer Unterschied und
spätestens in der Sekunde wo der Bund
Berlin diesen Förderantrag ausgestellt
kriegen soll muss der Staatssekretär
zuständige Staatssekretär sagen also in
dem Fall geht es wirklich nicht das ist
meine Schwester die dort in der
Verantwortung steht das kann ich leider
nicht machen das ist eben so und in der
Tat für Verwandte kann man nichts aber
in so einer spitzenpolitision muss man
wirklich genau aufgucken damit man nicht
sich einem filzvorwurf aussetzen ja
interessantes Thema vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung nach Berlin von
verloren
und wir schauen außerdem auf Tag 2 des
Europa-Rat Gipfels in Reykjavik der
Europarat ist eine der
ältesten politischen Institutionen in
Europa aber gar nicht so bekannt
Spitzenpolitiker aus 46 Ländern nehmen
am Gipfeltreffen teil und wir schalten
jetzt oder